da warten wir seit monaten auf das bild
aus dem zentrum der galaxie aus einem
weltumspannenden netz an teleskopen wird
es ja zurzeit aus unmengen von daten
errechnet da erreicht uns jetzt eines
mit details die wir so noch nie gesehen
haben jetzt könnt ihr endlich ein altes
rätsel gelöst werden worum es sich
handelt jetzt den klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
in rund 25.000 lichtjahren entfernung
liegt das zentrum unserer galaxie der
milchstraße
sie ist ja so genannt weil die
milliarden sterne aus denen sie besteht
am nachthimmel eher wie eine milchstraße
aussehen denn wie einzelne sterne und
die kann man auch nur auf dem land sehen
wo es keine lichtverschmutzung durch die
städtische beleuchtung gibt und das
zentrum unserer galaxie ist dann in
dieser milchstraße so weit von uns
entfernt dass es hinter den stern neben
und stoppt ansammlungen verborgen ist
aber es kann beobachtet werden wenn auch
nicht leicht aber mit radioteleskopen
sie fotografieren strahlung die bis zu
uns vor dringend gerade wurde das größte
seiner art auf der südhalbkugel in der
karoo wüste in südafrika eingeweiht und
schon liefert es ein spektakuläres bild
aus dem herzen unserer galaxie ist
bildet die strahlung rund um das
zentrale supermassereiche schwarze loch
im zentrum sagittarius a stern ab mehr
cat heißt das teleskop und besteht aus
64 radio antenne schüssel mit einem
durchmesser von jeweils 13 einhalb
metern und so deutlich wie es jetzt das
zentrum unserer milchstraße abgebildet
hat haben wir dieses noch nie gesehen es
war auch das erste ziel dass das neue
radioteleskop anvisieren sollte fernando
kamille vom seifigen radioastronomie
observatorio dazu es ist einzigartig
optisch eindrucksvoll und voller
unerklärt der phänomene aber auch
notorisch schwer mit radioteleskopen
abzubilden es ist also selbst mit
radioteleskopen eines der schwersten
motive doch die arbeit hat sich jetzt
gelohnt gut darauf zu sehen sind die
starken radio quellen rund um sarah
stern und aber auch zahlreiche dünne
filamente fäden die aus der region um
das schwarze loch nach oben und unten
heraus ragen sie wurden bereits in den
80er jahren des letzten jahrhunderts
entdeckt aber auch noch heute kann man
nichts über sie sagen welcher natur sind
sie woher kommen sie genau
zitat das mir cap bild zeigt nun viele
strukturen und merkmale die wir noch nie
zuvor gesehen haben das sagt farhat
josef cad von der northwestern
university in evanston darunter sind
beispielsweise kompakte radio quellen
die mit einigen dieser filamente
verknüpft zu sein scheinen
diese daten könnten den schlüssel
liefern um das drei jahrzehnte alte
rätsel um die filamente zu lösen
ja wenn ihr keine videos zur lösung
dieses rätsels und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte
aber ob sie auf youtube und verpasst
kann video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen andern vom neuesten video
und zwar täglich umquartiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür
hier klicken aber nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken foto von hubsen dem
schwarzen doch bis dann bleibt dran